it takes you know billions of dollars
years and years to do this safely
and uh as you've seen the decision was
to rush the whole thing
bypass almost everything
and start administering it into
a a very broad population a global
population
and do so
also bypassing this key thing that was
we all agreed on in the Western World at
least after World War II
uh called the Nuremberg Accords and the
Helsinki Accords uh and then in in
moving to the present
um we call this the common rule
in which people have to have be granted
informed consent and you absolutely
cannot uh coerce compel or entice
uh people to take an unlicensed medical
product that is just historically been
off limits
let's just do some like basic 101 stuff
for a moment before we get to your red
pill moment when when people are talking
about vaccines and and the difference
between the these mRNA vaccines and how
we've always done vaccines previously
can you give us just like a like a high
level version of that and and sort of
when did you become concerned that there
was a difference in what was going on
here
so I think what you're talking about is
not what is the nature of a vaccine in
terms of the technology but rather what
is the process to bring a vaccine to
Market
and that's typically about a 10-year
timeline
to illustrate the point the Department
of Defense if everything goes well and
it never does is on track to have
vaccines licensed for all
uh infectious disease agents that were
deployed in biowarfare up until the end
of World War II and if everything goes
right they'll have all those vaccines by
2050. a full Century after the end of
World War II okay so we gotta we gotta
basically a 10 10-year timeline to
really do it right
and that involves a significant
non-clinical research toxicology
pharmacody distribution
genotoxicity a whole bunch of things
that just got blown off
uh to make sure that that it's safe
enough to go into humans in the first
place
and then once it's in humans It Go
typically a vaccine goes through a very
staged process of phase one trials
typically a couple of different phase
one trials phase two expanded trials
phase one is typically just kind of
preliminary estimates of safety with low
numbers you know here's an important
thing to know uh in vaccinology we use
the rule of three
um and and the way this works is if you
want to detect an adverse event that
occurs in one in a thousand people
generally you have to test 3 000 people
if you wanted to text something that
happens 1 in 30
okay or one in ten I was going to say
one and ten then you'd have to test 30
people okay so that's kind of phase one
trial right level one you know one in
ten is stuff that happens a lot pretty
much to everybody Right One In A
Thousand is is something that matters a
lot if you're going to be administering
it to large populations which generally
is the case with vaccines unless you're
talking about Special Forces or
something for some obscure pathogen uh
and then when you really get to uh you
know Global deployment or national
deployment you want to have sample sizes
in the kind of three hundred thousand uh
range uh you know this is what the FDA
is typically required in the past for
um uh new adjuvants for example for a
vaccine
but in this case kind of all the rules
went out the door in the rush uh in all
the fear that was actively promoted
uh and so when you when you do it that
stepwise fashion and then typically what
happens is you you first kind of move it
forward in healthy normal adults
because they have lowest risks they can
handle insults biologic insults best
and then then you move to elderly people
and special populations like
immunosuppressed and those kinds of
things and you do a step down into the
little babies okay so first you do
adolescence and then you do first you
young adults and you do adolescents they
need new children then you do uh you
know young very young and then you can
go down to neonates if you have to
so that's the general process and to do
all that takes enormous amount of time
and the cost per subject
uh for a well-run trial is something it
starts at about ten thousand per person
generally if you if you really mind your
nickels you can get it down to about
five or eight thousand per person and it
goes up to about thirty or forty
thousand per person so you can do the
math and uh you quickly come up to some
serious serious cash uh so it it takes
you know billions of dollars
um years and years to do this safely
and uh as you've seen the decision was
to rush the whole thing
uh bypass almost everything
um and uh started ministering it into
uh a very broad population a global
population
and do so
also bypassing this key thing that was
we all agreed on in the Western World at
least after World War II
uh called the Nuremberg Accords and the
Helsinki Accords uh and then in in
moving to the present
um we call this the common rule
in which people have to have be granted
informed consent and you absolutely
cannot uh coerce compel or entice
uh people to take an unlicensed medical
product that is just historically been
off limits we all agreed nope Germans
did that that you know everybody thinks
about what happened in Nazi Germany uh
the story of what happened in Japan is
even uglier
uh the Japanese biowarfare program was
uh you know truly atrocious in terms of
the bioethics
and uh as I guess Bobby is going to
point out in his next book
Bobby Kennedy uh just like we imported a
lot of the rocket scientists uh to
launch NASA so to speak uh we imported
both German but particularly the
Japanese biowarfare experts and the
records associated with that uh up to
Fort Detrick in Frederick Maryland to
launch our bio Warfare program
which after Nixon made the determination
that we were going to put in place the
um biowarfare treaty uh got transformed
into a biodefense program the same
people doing the same stuff pretty much
uh and that's that's kind of where
that's all gone it's it's not a pretty
picture
uh and and the deeper you look into it
in the bio Labs that we set up in
Georgia the former Soviet state and then
presumably the bio Labs that we set up
in Ukraine
uh
those those uh offshore bio Labs uh
have a long Rich history of ethical
abuses let's say gently
um so it's it's a it's a mixed bag here
um there's a lot of
there's there's I I do believe that
there is an unmet need
uh and that was the logic for advancing
the RNA Tech in theory
was there absolutely is an unmet need
for ability to respond rapidly to
engineered pathogens and emerging
infectious disease but uh
I
I think personally that what's been done
will basically destroy Global public
confidence in any of this kind of
activity for the foreseeable future if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell